[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les ministres chers collègues femmes vit
liberté ces trois mots se propagent à
travers le monde en soutien au
courageusement iranienne qui brûlent
leur voile pour réclamer l'abolition
d'une loi qui les oblige à se couvrir
symbole de la soumission et l'oppression
des femmes dans une société patriarcale
face à un pouvoir théocratique dont elle
ne supporte plus le carcan le
gouvernement va-t-il enfin admettre que
le voile est un étendard politique au
religieux quand on Iran le voile semble
être la pierre angulaire du régime des
mots là je regrette encore votre
attitude d'opposition à tous les
amendements que nous avions déposés dans
le cadre de la loi séparatisme et que
vous avez qualifié d'amendement textile
alors qu'aujourd'hui clairement les
entraves à la laïcité dans nos écoles
augmente de manière inquiétante et que
les abayas les camises fleurissent dans
les lycées signe de l'influence
islamiste et particulièrement des Frères
musulmans qui se diffusent dans l'esprit
d'une partie de notre jeunesse quand le
gouvernement va-t-il enfin avoir un
discours et des directives très claires
sur ce sujet